payson if I was welcome to another
exciting edition of instant trailer
review today we're looking at sin city a
dame to kill for yes the sequel to the
2005 robert rodriguez film which was
actually quite revolutionary at the time
because if you ever watch the behind the
scenes of Sin City the first one robber
shot a lot of these actors against green
screen not even in the same room with
each other he shot like six actors all
in different days and combine it all
together in editing so that was actually
like a really a big deal at the time
because no one had never really done
that before and sometimes it really
looks and feels that way yeah you just
have to be on board for what this
movie's going for and it's trying to
create that graphic novel Phil yeah the
motion so for a long time the sequel was
sort of delayed because Angelina Jolie
was supposed to play the amyl Lord
character was not played by Olivia Ava
green believe yeah all right yeah Casino
Royale but now they finally a sequel and
here's the trailer we're going to go
into it and it's interesting that this
should come out the same here has this
sequel or the whatever this fed off the
300 is BK these are both Frank movies
that are like 77 years too late as well
basic because I mean those movies were
both big deals when they came out in
2005-2006 but they waited until 2014 it
actually come out so we have a shot of
Nancy played by Jessica Alba here now
according to wikipedia what we read is
that they're supposed to be four
different stories and one of them
involves Nancy sort of sad and depressed
over the loss of her lover / older man
boyfriend cardigan played by Bruce
Willis yeah so this is the fat loss
that's that storyline that seems to be
going on and then in classic since the
detail you know everyone's got guns and
i love the film noir black and white /
you know over-the-top angles and
everyone's oh yeah just a [ __ ] out of
each other the shadows alone in this are
just so exciting to look and just like
all the details like up up there looking
at again in the window what's going on
freely other's eyes yeah yes really
owners in this I mean there's a big cast
and i assume is the same text tactic
that robber
his hat is with let's get a lot of big
celebrities shoot them for one day and a
green screen and then just cause it
later and Josh Brolin he's actually
taking over the Clive Owen roll yes but
the character's name is Dwight and if
anyone's read the books you know that he
gets plastic surgery it's not a spoiler
or anything because it's mentioned in
the first movie so he gets plastic
surgeries to look different so it
actually does fit they go to different
that's how they can explain away yeah
the recast and there's actually several
people who have been recast Michael
Clarke Duncan unfortunately passed away
so he couldn't reprise his role they I
will see some more as we go through this
um so yeah we have next we analyzed
Joseph gordon-levitt's in this now just
in the first 10 nominees playing a
character who's a gambler named Johnny
and that's apparently going to be one of
the new storyline yet it's not from the
comics or the graphic novels I should
say and one thing about sin city is
always an interesting use of color I
mean isn't black and white within this
certain elements are in blue or certain
lips are red or there's the character
that yellow bastard who is yellow so
said city and Schindler's lives both
have that in common um so yeah so much
and we see Bruce Willis oh yeah who that
is died in the other one and so what I
read is that some prequel moments in
this when we kind of go back and forth
in time so is this actually a scene from
the original sin city of you I don't
think rusev around then the original and
actually if you look in the corner here
this poster it says booze broads and
bullets it's kind of blocked but this is
actually the cover to one of the other
books that are series of short stories
um sleep and we have gamblers you know
prostitutes corrupt politicians and I
believe this is christopher lloyd right
here this is dumped around I'm kind of
shocked at you'd be in the Joseph
gordon-levitt showing up at his door
apparently he's really desperate and
everyone just lives in like this kind of
poverty basic yeah so very run down Las
Vegas kind of feel City it really lives
up to its name and in the comics it's
actually the reason is called since
is short for pheasants that he was
really amazing and then that's yeah we
have who's this Emma green playing a
character named Ava Lord who's the lover
of Josh Brolin's character Dwight and
that's sort of the main storyline I
biggest storyline she is the dame to
kill for because she's supposed to be an
amazing woman that he absolutely is yeah
I have a I have a thing there's people
who spend what nine years since the
first movie yeah hover people who
haven't read the graphic novels are they
going to be completely lost I feel like
the movie theater needs to give us like
a character chart it's true i mean you
know you were if you saw this movie you
know nine years ago I feel like you're a
different demographic because I think
this movie is kind of appealing to like
thirteen to twenty two year olds and you
guys aren't really that age anymore I
mean maybe it's a feeling of a different
age group now but you know if you read
the graphic novels in the 90s you know
like there's a span of 20 years to these
stories and so the audience is kind of
all over the place I think at this point
sure so here we have a shot away I'm
assuming is josh brolin just sitting in
a chair doing this or like falling down
and elevators down I don't look very
green screening it looks like david o
russell driving that car today I'm sure
it's not and so yeah if you're on board
to the visual style these things won't
bother you and because I'm such a oh if
you want to go back to that that's
actually I believe Dennis Haysbert from
24 thing who's going to be playing the
Michael Clarke Duncan roll yeah so
everything is you know shadows and
silhouettes I love when they do the
white / black so this trailer
specifically shows everything very fast
so I mean you don't see much and you
don't really get that much sense of
story but everybody knows
that a you know what would these
characters are and then here's all the
celebrities were going to be in this
there's a lot yeah Mickey Rourke comes
back as Marv who i believe died the
first one yeah yeah when he comes back
stacy keach i mean that that's exciting
i just love seeing these our actors that
you normally would never see together in
a movie here's they have a green again
who's also in the 300 films gianna me
she's has been part of both of these
Frank Miller franchises and her green
eyes that's that's really nice touch as
well so I'm kind of thinking that Johnny
this Joseph gordon-levitt character
might sort of be like the the book ends
and like a running thread throughout
this whole thing yeah I believe Josh
Hartnett had a similar role like that in
the last one so there you go um not in
3d at least not that we've been able to
see and this is actually a movie people
don't normally say this but I would love
to see this in 3d I think that would go
along with the visuals and then head
yeah so Robert Rodriguez as a director I
mean he's he has really done too much
that like in the last decade I mean he's
done you know it is a spy kids movies
but he's coming back with something like
I said work out the machete stuff yeah
the machete stuff I would ya put like
the box office watch those weren't that
big no that's why they weren't like this
is probably going to blow up the box
office the same way as the other since
that he did yeah so Frank Miller always
has something in the movies that's we're
seeing ya so August 22nd it's really
interesting actually to see the little
miramax logo we haven't seen that in
movies for probably five years or so and
it's because this one has been so long
in the development process I mean so
that's kind of cool to see miramax
coming back and won't see that off so
yeah um to conclude I'm excited for
since 82 it's as good as the books it
has been a long time since the last sin
city so I hope it's just as interesting
yeah it was one of my most anticipated
films of 2013 but it got pushed back so
I'm still very eager to see it i love
the first film so for movie clips on Jas
and I'm David thanks for watching